ce à quoi servez-vous ya des raisins le
petit déjeuner a été préparé pour vous
ce matin la journée de ces petits
habitants de volga plage commence par un
bon petit déjeuner équilibré
parce qu'à la maison tu ne manges pas ce
genre de non tu manges le match de
l'année au centre de loisirs qui leur a
ouvert ses portes aujourd'hui ses
enfants de 5 à 16 ans bénéficie d'une
attention particulière
une proximité qui a toute son importance
des fois les parts ne leur donne pas à
manger alors on veut plus passer une
bonne journée qui se tiennent bien alors
on leur donne un petit on leur offre
petit déjeuner tous les jours et après
s'être bien régalé la digestion se
poursuit en douceur rythmé par les
comptes de compellent a peint une petite
pause culturelle au bord des berges de
volga les vacances sont bien meilleurs
comme ça j'aime bien parce que c'est
aussi à des ti qui se base beaucoup je
m'amusais coupé cela au sens te permet
de sortir de son cadre habituel de la au
dessus on ne donnait ses genoux sinon je
suis dans la zone où les secousses
auraient fait quoi si c'est à la maison
en banlieue
à l'initiative de l'association volga
plage le centre de loisirs met
aujourd'hui en place un panel
d'activités des balades ou randonnées en
passant par divers ateliers
l'objectif est d'offrir à ses enfants
des vacances comme tous les autres
beaucoup d enfants
des fois non pas les moyens ou ne sont
pas partis en vacances donc panama il
est important de leur apporter d'autres
distractions d'autres formes de
distraction de profiter de sa
disponibilité pour faire des apports
culturels mieux se connaître
jusqu'au 31 août les enfants du quartier
de volga plage poursuivront leurs
vacances scolaires sourire aux lèvres